thank you very much I'm grateful for
this opportunity to speak I think
probably the most disruptive technique
in the history of neuroscience is the
first technique in the history of
neuroscience the the Golgi technique
which was developed by Camille Golgi
when he was thirty years old playing
around in his kitchen with the chemicals
that are used in photographic emulsions
and he no one really knows there's a lot
of biography of him written a few years
ago that tries to figure out how he
generated this technique but he no one
really knows and in that book also says
it's kind of mysterious but he was
playing around in his kitchen and he
found a staining technique where he
mixed together silver nitrate and
potassium dichromate he used the silver
nitrate and potassium dichromate because
together they make a silver dichromate
crystal and he found a technique that
was at first sight you might think
really terrible because it was
extraordinarily inefficient it was not a
very good technique of course that
turned out to be its magic had this
technique worked well and stained nerve
cells completely a piece of brain
instead of being a kind of yellowish
white would have been completely brown
everything would have been labeled and
you wouldn't learn anything but what
made this such a remarkable technique
which he called the black reaction
product I guess it would have been
bragging for him to call it the Golgi
technique but everybody else since then
has called it the Golgi technique it had
this remarkable ability to label a small
subset of nerve cells in their entirety
but most nerve cells and in fact the
cells it labeled were not nerve cells
they were just random cells in the brain
but the brain has got a large number of
nerve cells but glial cells endothelial
cells other kinds of cells in the brain
are also labeled but all at very low
density 1% 5
percent depending on how you mix the
ingredients together and the idea was
that the fixation that was done with the
dichromate and the nitrate maintained
the membranes so that if a crystal of
silver dichromate formed that was an
itis for further crystallization but the
crystals couldn't break through the
membranes so they just kept running down
the processes of cells and you could see
for the first time much more easily than
ever before individual nerve cells
what made this technique disruptive
though was and he was certainly a genius
that named Golgi comes up over and over
again it's always the same Golgi who did
all those all the gold cheese you know
about our him so he's quite an
impressive guy but one thing that was
not impressive I think was his ability
to understand what he was looking at
there was another genius and and that is
Santiago Ramon Eco was a Spaniard
he and qahal frankly hated each other
they they did not get along they only
met in person at the Nobel Prize they
shared and Golgi spent his entire
lecture you should if you're interested
you should read his lecture it's just an
attack on kaha completely and it was
really he shouldn't have done that
because Kyle really was a genius you
know qahal looked at this material and
he inferred something that was very
disruptive in the sense that it it
provided a hypothesis about the way the
brain worked that didn't exist before
his brilliant insight and and that
insight came from drawings there he is
in later life he he by the way was a
great photographer he took thousands and
thousands of pictures of Santiago Ramon
Iike how he loved taking his own picture
his hand is almost always clenched in
his pictures because he's squeezing the
bulb of the flash from young age all the
way to advanced stage
but what made him remarkable was this
ability to look at this material and
infer something and this is a one of his
drawings the paper has yellowed he
apparently used whiteout he did make
mistakes the white has stood the test of
time much better than the paper this is
not snow on trees this is a just a sign
of his courage
you know his sort of meticulous
correcting of things that we probably
wouldn't notice but for him everything
was always done perfectly exactly right
but what made his pictures so remarkable
were these little arrows he inferred
just by looking at brains that that
nervous system cells neurons are
connected in a directional network he
claimed that the axons of cells and
here's an axon coming from a cell
somewhere else terminates in a bunch of
branches that overlap the dendrites of
other cells the receptive part of other
cells and at this point of contact
information of some sort passed from the
axon into the dendrites which flows into
the cell body and then the cell sends
that information out its own axon that
axon might overlap with the apical
dendrites of this pyramidal cell that
information notice this arrow sends that
information into the dendrite down the
apical dendrite to the cell body and at
the same time here's another axon
innervating the basal dendrites of this
pyramidal cell and these inputs in some
way are collaborating to generate a
signal that leaves this cell out its
axon and that axon touches the dendrites
of another cell which sends that
information out its axon and that axon
goes on and does the same and here in
one fell swoop was a profound idea based
not on Physiology not on calcium imaging
not on anything other than looking at
Golgi stain material and to a first
approximation he basically got it right
he nailed it I mean we we to this day
largely believed this idea there are of
course we now know back propagating
action potentials in dendrites which he
didn't know we know that many neurons
are inhibitory and that
they're not trying to send information
on but they're trying to stop
information cahal was not able to see
that but in a general sense this notion
the important thing is that based on the
sparse labeling of the golgi he was able
to generate a concept that frankly
anyone could understand it's simple
enough to understand and there's nothing
like a simple idea because simple ideas
are powerful because you can hold them
in your head and they generalize to the
whole brain in fact this idea is so
dominant that to this day for all of us
in neuroscience if we have to if someone
says tell me the circuit in the retina
or tell me the circuit in the cerebellum
or tell me the circuit in the cortex we
draw diagrams that are very cahal yin
and here's Rudolfo
enos in 2002 drawing a modern version of
the way cells from the thalamus
innervate pyramidal cells in the cortex
he has added of course the important
feature that there are now also
inhibitory neurons but you can see in
this diagram these arrows you can just
trace this back to this particular
worldview so this is the sparse world
view and I think for many of us and I
think much of what we've heard today us
shows that we're still I wouldn't say
mired in this because there's nothing
really wrong with it but that this is
sort of what most people think neural
circuits are like even though these are
really canonical circuits and I'm going
to speak more about that I want to just
sort of emphasize the qahal understood
the limitations of of the sparse
technique and that they really do ignore
a lot of information that's probably
part of the network's he-he in many of
his stains he modified the labeling with
the Golgi technique to generate more
cells labeled and I'll just gonna show
you a little drawing of the upper layer
layer 1 and 2 of cortex of a
where he had labeled more cells and
here's here's his drawing of that well
this is layer 1 up here it's a little
slab of brain and you look here for
those arrows you're not gonna find any
of them and that's because he was a
genius he wasn't an idiot he knew it was
just be impossible to make any kind of
arrow diagram out of this and you know
that I think this is a it's something
sooner or later we have to confront
which is what is the real circuits like
what actually is driving a cell not what
types of cells but what actually is
driving a cell and so I'd like to
emphasize a little bit about what's
missing from this qahal Ian one neuron
type to another neuron type circuit
analysis which is is basically where the
present state of the art is and where I
would argue disruptive technologies of
the future is going to have to get us
beyond so what's missing well one thing
is of course quantitative details how
many inter neurons of a particular type
are innervating a target cell are not
known how many excitatory cells are
being are driving a particular target
cell how many different target cells
does each axon drive and where are they
and what is every single one of them and
how strong is it is each contact of an
axon with every one of the target cells
it didn't it innervates these kind of
fan out fan in quantitative details are
missing from sparse labeling techniques
the second kind of information that's
missing I think is that if you look at
the behavioral repertoire of animals
like us humans most especially but other
mammals you see that there's a lot of
our behaviors that are not genetically
encoded and the importance of that like
for example riding a bicycle it's not
that you have a gene called bicycling
that lets you ride a bicycle you know
you have a circuit that is developed in
you if you had the opportunity to learn
how to write
and once you've got that circuit you can
ride a bicycle for the rest of your life
if you didn't get that circuit during a
critical period it's much harder to ride
a bicycle that's not because people who
ride bicycles have a particular cell
type that's connected to another cell
type that in other people it isn't it's
that's probably among the connections of
cells of a particular type the exact
particular cells that a cell innervates
probably underlie a function we have
known for example for 30 40 years
exactly what the canonical circuit of
the cerebellum is it's there's just not
too many there's a handful of cell types
there but the way the cerebellum works
is still deeply mysterious because we
don't have any idea about which
particular climbing fibers are
associated which with which particular
parallel fibers we know what kinds of
connections they make but we don't know
who is innovating exactly who so and
that probably is all related to
experience based connectivity if we want
to get somewhere understanding that
we've gonna have to start looking at the
nervous system at a slightly different
level experience based connectivity as
opposed to genetically based
categorizations which are based on an
intrinsic molecular or morphological
differences between cells these
experienced ones require us to do
something somewhat different how might
we look at differences in the
connectivity among neurons of a single
class not between classes but how does
one class parse its intervation out and
mapping out wiring diagrams at that
level is sort of like mapping out all
the genes not just the gene you're
interested in at one particular time but
what is all the genes that are active at
a particular time exactly which genes
are participating in each phenotype not
just a few but all of them and in genes
we call this genomics and probably
transcriptomics eventually in the
nervous system we might call this
connect omics a kind of mapping of all
the connections this is I know a new
term for most of you so I brought the
dictionary definition connectomics or
connectomics
has two pronunciations it's a
but singular in construction this by the
way is from mirin Webster's unabridged
in 2019
it's a branch of biotechnology
technology important concerned with
applying the techniques of computer
assisted image acquisition and analysis
computers have to play a role here to
the structural mapping of sets of neural
circuits or perhaps even to the complete
nervous system of selected organisms
using high speeds methods you've got to
go fast or you'll never finish I'll try
to make that quite clear a little later
and then you have to organize those
results in databases and by databases
here probably don't mean Excel
spreadsheets which is what most of us
think of as databases this is image
databases - image databases the hardest
thing to do it's it's quite challenging
we're working on this a lot now and
applying this data as in neurology or
psychiatry there are probably diseases
of connections in this dictionary you
can look up the word connect apathy and
you'll find that that's diseases of
wiring diagrams at the moment there are
no known connect appa these but many
people suspect autism and perhaps
certain obsessive-compulsive neuroses
certain learning disorders other kinds
of newer negative disorders might be
connected with ease
and fundamental neuroscience questions
like what does bicycle writing look like
in your brain how or what does your
grandmother's memory look like what is
what is the structure of a memory and if
you did the whole wiring diagram you'd
get the connectome the equivalent of a
genome we began thinking the simplest
way to do this was to take advantage of
the cahal idea but multiplex sparse
labeling but use a lot of colors and
that was this rainbow technique which
has been extraordinarily useful as
screen savers
it's been really great many of you have
them I'm sure good but the the goal was
not screensavers the goal was to parse
out cells of a particular tight look in
the dentate gyrus every single cell as a
unique entity and we have been working
on improving this technique we have new
versions of it now where we can use
these gen to rainbow lines that Darwin
Tsai made and this is a collaboration
with Josh Saenz where the labeling is
much brighter all the labeling is in the
membranes of cells and we're now using
immuno lis immunologically distinct
fluorescent proteins for each of the
colors so we can enhance with Alexa dyes
and this now means it's very easy to
trace axons very very long distances
even when they're all labeled because
each one is unique color I would I
thought we had invented something really
profound here but this had been invented
previously so what but but but for the
same purpose to try to figure out what
computer how computers work humans
decided to label the wires so if you
label axons like this and go out to the
periphery you can see the synapses of
every single axon these are all motor
neurons from the same group of motor
neurons that innervate a muscle and now
we have cellular distinctions not class
distinctions but among cells of one
class I can say with certainty these two
neuromuscular junctions on two invisible
muscle fiber cylinders are from the same
neuron in the spinal cord this is from a
different one this is from a different
one and so on and from this and you know
this is all membrane labeled in these
newer ones and I just give you I'm not
going to talk much about results here
but just give you a sense that you can
now map out all the wires of all the
axons going to a muscle distinctly and
this won't take forever because it's a
very small muscle that wiggles the ears
they're only 15 axons here I'm just
going to put them in one at a time and
this told us many interesting things
them were a little alarming one is that
this wiring diagram when you looked at
it and it's mirror symmetrical version
on the other side they weren't mirror
symmetrical even close every single
instantiation of this wiring diagram was
unique and we now know this is because
of the way this wiring diagram is
instantiated in mammals and a mouse
through a reorganization of wires and
development many of the branches are
pruned and the ones that stay are a
subset of the ones that started I don't
really want to talk about the biology
that's my main interest but that's not
my main purpose today so this works
really great for a peripheral nervous
system but most of you don't care about
muscle I'm resigned to that fact and and
and you kind of want to say well what
about doing this and the cortex and you
know here is a Golgi stain like picture
but it's done with brain bow now but in
order to make sense out of this you've
got to parse out all these little wires
and the trouble is when you do this with
the highest resolution normal light
microscopy with confocal with a pinhole
all the way down Nyquist sampling so you
over sampled by a factor of two big
surprise there's just a huge number of
wires there and and they're too many
actually it's very hard with light
microscopy to sort out the wires when
they're all labeled we have come up with
techniques for subsampling a new set of
rainbow viruses that are av viruses that
generate each virus generates two colors
and we have two separate viruses and if
we make the mix those together in an
animal that let's say expresses Cree in
PV positive positive cells then you can
see just the inhibitory neurons and in
the brain the pv positive inhibitory
cells so these big dark ovals are the
pyramidal cell bodies and now the
labeling is sparse enough that one can
generate a map of inhibitory neurons but
that's not what I'm really after what if
you want to see all the connections so
we went to a different technique we
built a machine that is basically an
electron microscopy technician
but it works all day and all night and
on Christmas Eve and it never complains
occasionally breaks but if you fix it it
keeps on working and this is an
interesting idea that Ken Hayworth came
up with he's now at janelia farm but
when he worked with me he designed a
machine that basically gave us the
opportunity to generate a limitless
number of sections of brain in a way
that's lossless largely non-destructive
and the sections are very sturdy it this
looks a little bit like maybe a movie
projector and it has something in common
with movie projectors in the sense you
start out with with a film with nothing
on it and then after it goes through
this part of the movie projector you end
up with a basically a movie of frames
each of these is a separate section of
the brain so all of this stuff is just
to move a conveyor belt of tape very
close to a place where a piece of brain
is being sliced quite thin so the action
is up here and it's just a
high-resolution view of this you have
this block of brain that's hardened
that's been put in a heavy resin for
electron microscopy and this is a Chuck
moving up and down and it shaves off a
thin section into water section floats
on water and then is picked up by a
continuously moving conveyor belt and we
can generate about 12,000 sections per
day now we started about 1,000 now we
can go much faster the sections we're
cutting our thin by e/m standards we're
cutting at 30 nanometers we can cut down
to 25 nanometers we like thin because
many of the ambiguities of
reconstructing wires become trivial when
the sections are thin as you'll see so
we're cutting very thin and then we're
putting the sections on a tape so the
brain ends up being from a block it
becomes the brain on tape which now
looks just like a big tape and the tape
can be depending on how many sections
you cut but many many many meters long
and then we take the tape and we cut it
two sections each of these is a brain
section 30 nanometers next to the next
one and then we paste those on to a flat
wafer that has got a conductive
substrate on it I'll explain why it's
conductive in a second and we keep doing
that until we have an ultra-thin section
library basically the brain has now been
linearized for us and each section is 30
nanometers above and below the section
before it here's for example Josh Morgan
a guy who's been working on this for a
while has completed a data set of the
thalamus of the visual thalamus the
dorsal lateral geniculate this is 10,000
sections 55 wafers the wafers are about
the size of a CD wafer and this is about
100 terabyte data set now I'm going to
just show you one of these wafers this
is what a wafer looks like here are the
individual sections occasionally a
section comes off crooked our algorithms
find all the sections and when we image
them we correct the orientation of the
imaging optics which we're using
electron microscope so these don't cause
us much trouble anymore and if we look
at one of these sections at somewhat
higher resolution in this case it's
about a millimeter by a millimeter the
first thing you notice are the blood
vessels and then these littler things
are neurons and in between the neurons
are the wires that connect these cells
and this is the optical optic fibers
coming from the optic tract coming from
the retina the retinal ganglion cell
axons that are diving in and innervating
these cells and then in this region what
Josh did is he took an image of this
area at the resolution that we could see
every synaptic vesical okay so that
required that this image is maybe 2
microns per pixel and this image I'll
just zoom up on that one this image here
is at 4 nanometers per pixel and it's
point 4 millimeters by 0.4 millimeters
at 4 nanometers so that means it's
actually
hundred thousand pixels by a hundred
thousand pixels this screen is probably
generating something about a thousand
pixels by a thousand pixels so this
image is actually a hundred times wider
if you can imagine that and a hundred
times taller than this picture so if you
imagine how big that is you if you were
sitting here you wouldn't be able to
look at it you'd have to really back up
hundreds of yards and that would look
just like this so there's no real point
in trying to show you the full picture
there and so he did that and then he had
to do that that's a bit so it's on a
megapixel image it's a 10 billion pixel
image and then he did that ten thousand
three hundred times for each of the
images I'm gonna show you most of those
images here because there's a lesson to
learn the first thing is if you look at
this your eye will be drawn to this
particular image and this particular
image these are images when the
microscope for unknown reasons because
this is all automated imaging said no I
don't want to take a picture right now
and when it does that we have to go back
and take that picture again it's not we
know where it came from you know we can
find the right thing but we don't want
to do that here's a bunch of images
where the images got progressively
darker for unknown reasons and here's a
bunch of images that got progressively
lighter again for unknown reasons and
you know we explained to the microscope
company this is really a problem and
they look at this and say yeah it's just
so uniform up here it's beautiful
I'm sure you've all had the same issues
with companies they always have the
glass is always half full for them but
for us it's half empty so we're trying
to get these companies to be more robust
but it's true they say you know you're
just running these machines all day all
night every single day and you're
generating a terabyte a day in this case
what did you expect and then we said
well you know if it can do it here it
should be able to do it everywhere so
this is still a technological challenge
but the end of the day you have this
very end of the 3.3 months I should say
you you have a huge data set here
is 100 terabyte black of brain thalamus
at the level of synaptic vesicles it's
huge in one respect but in another
respect it's not so big this is its size
it happens to be exactly the size of a
grain of salt so take it with a grain of
salt if you will it's very small and and
this is one of our serious problems that
this took three point three months just
to generate the data much less analyze
it we have to go faster and for example
instead of doing that in three months I
would like to do that in days I'd like
to be able to do cubic millimeters and
that was only 0.4 by 0.4 by 0.4 mil so
it's a much much smaller than a cubic
millimeter in weeks I'd like to be doing
instead of a terabyte a day I'd like to
be doing multiple terabytes an hour and
I mention all this because we've been
working with Carl Zeiss with a team
there who have been building a machine
that goes fast enough to go this fast
this is the original prototype it's a
gigantic ly expensive machine and also a
gigantic machine it is a it's it's
equivalent to having 61 electron
microscopes because instead of having
one scanning electron beam it has 61
beams that scan in parallel and that
allows us to probably get two billion
pixel per second imaging speed it's it's
huge on me and that's a normal-sized
person I come up to about here
and it's got you know you've got to be
sending out 61 beams of information we
are getting ours the first of its kind
will be delivered in on June 4th to the
lab that one that we're getting is much
spelter than that it's very very tall
but but it's thinner which is probably
good and 61 beams you may be wondering
why 61 beams it's that the beams are
actually a hexagon of little beams and
that one beam in the center is the one
that gives you the 61 beam so each of
these beams is imaging a little square
of data and it uses secondary electrons
and the images are quite beautiful so
let me just give you a sense of what
images look like that come off either
this machine or single beam machines
Bobby Kasturi
who was here is the person who kind of
optimized the way we would image these I
asked him to hold his hand really still
as we zoom in on one of these sections
just so you can get a sense of what they
look like here and about now he's
holding his breath and going into the
vacuum of the electron microscope but
he's got really steady hands your blood
vessels here are nerve cells and these
white things are the apical dendrites of
cortical neurons these black outlined
objects are myelinated axons as we zoom
up further finally you'll see a vesicle
filled profile of an X I'm making a
synapse onto a dendritic spine spine
apparatus of a dendrite so that's one
section but basically you do this for
many many sections so this is still for
us quite low resolution we take our
images at 3 nanometer resolution and
this is a hundred times lower resolution
10 10 and X and 10 and Y and these are
neurons that we're just cutting through
this is not time-lapse this is space
lapse if you will that's the nucleus of
a cell and these things that are moving
around are not really moving in time
they're just moving through this volume
I'm sure most of you are familiar with
the notion of
optical sectioning so these big white
things are the apical dendrites of cells
the myelinated axons are obvious there
and in between all this are little wires
which I'll show you in a second I know
this image looks like it was taken in
1904 and that's partly because of the
underlying tape we've pretty much fixed
that problem but at the end of this you
you generate a box of brain now and that
box of brain again has high resolution
data in and if we look at it at closer
to full resolution you can see it's just
filled with this is just take a second
to run normally little wires which are
mainly axons synapses vesicle filled
profiles and if you if your eye just
picks one of these objects you probably
can trace it pretty easily from section
to section I just randomly picked one
here in fact if you could get a couple
of five-year-olds with big a lot of
crayons and and just gave them a big
coloring book and said you know if you
color this red in one page when you get
to the next page colored in the same
color you should be able to get this
whole wiring diagram we we have been
using college students for our doing
this coloring but you know there's a
limit to how much people want to do so
we've been true shiiin should be able to
do this right and this doesn't seem that
hard it turns out it is quite hard to do
but thanks to work with hans-peter
Pfister who's an engineer at Harvard in
the engineering department he has a crew
who works on this every day and they've
done quite a good job of making an
automatic algorithm where this is all
colored in now automatically and then
you can follow objects it if you look at
any object and you see it changes color
it's a it's a place where the algorithm
has failed it should never change color
and the algorithm gets better almost
weekly now it's it's getting much better
but we still have to edit it it's not
perfect and it doesn't know what to do
with Golgi apparatus so you get these
psychedelic Golgi but we don't care
about Golgi
we just let that pass so I'm almost done
here but so what we do is we hand
correct the automatic segmentation
what's shown here are two cylinders a
green cylinder and a red cylinder where
I swear everything is correct and I know
everything's correct because everything
is connected to an edge that is there's
no orphan material there everything in
these cylinders everything there's
nothing left every cytoplasmic object in
the red cylinder and the green cylinder
has been reconstructed we saturate the
reconstruction and as we say and the red
cylinder is a cylinder around an apical
dendrite that is labeled red in this
diagram you'll see it come back here and
the cylinder diameter is one that covers
all of its dendritic spines so here is
the red dendrite and the green cylinder
it is around a green dendrite and the
yellow stuff you see in here is the
Galea
so everything yellow are the astrocytes
so here's the green apical dendrite so
here are those two dendrites they have a
lot of spines we see a greater density
of spines than people normally report
and that's because we everything has to
be segmented so all of these spine heads
have to be traced back so every spine
had in that volume got traced back and
so we end up with lots of dendritic
spines but in this little area there's a
cylinder here that's 30 microns long and
a cylinder here that's 15 microns long
it's 1500 cubic microns there are a lot
more dendrites than just those two here
are all the dendrites in there that's
the green dendrite that's that green
spine that was sticking out near the
edge there's the red dendrite so there's
a lot of dendrites packed in there but
that's the dendrites there's also a hell
of a lot of axons in there here all the
axons it doesn't you know you can see
where the dendrites are the axons aren't
but there's a lot of axons in there and
there's a lot of glia in there all this
stuff is in there
and I want to put this into perspective
I I know I'm running out of time very
quickly here but this is the red
dendrite cylinder and I just want to
show you what actually is in there first
of all I want to remind you how much
we've actually accomplished here so this
cylinder sits inside a cortical mini
column starting from layer 6 up to layer
1 this is the cortical Milic milli mini
column but that cylinder is there so
it's it's actually about one billionth a
mouse brain so we're on our way but
what's what's really depressing about
this I I just don't know any other way
to say but depressing is that when you
actually look at what's in there yikes
there's so much in there I mean there's
really a lot of stuff and this is just
within the confines of the dendritic
spines of one cell one little part of it
know what's in there there's a 696 axons
83 different dendrites 774 synapse is
mostly excitatory and the last picture
I'll show you is that with this we've
begun to map out the wiring diagram such
as we can in such a small area and we're
very surprised to find that on any of
the dendrites but I'm just going to show
you the red dendrite the same axon will
find the dendritic spines of the same
cell multiple times 30% of our axons
find the same dendrite more than once
often not next to each other so all of
the green axons here are making three
synapses on these dendritic spines and
all of the yellow ones are making two
and yet there's these spines are only
12% of the spines in their vicinity and
they if they find it once they have a
very high chance of finding it again so
just to say finally the future of this
field and I think a lot of neurobiology
is related to what we're going to do
with all this information I grew up in a
time of really big ideas
in neuroscience and and these big ideas
were unfettered by information it was an
age of big ideas and little data and now
we're entering an age of big data and
unfortunately I think what goes out the
window with big data is big ideas you
know when you have no information you
have profound understanding but as
information goes up your understanding
goes down this is the challenge for your
generation and good luck with it thank
you very much
instructions one is that you had some
dendrites that were actually four I mean
some spines that were actually four and
others that had multiple bulges along
their shaft so are those actually all
synaptic site are those bulges synaptic
sites and 99% of the spines have one
synapse in this area one percent have
two if they have two almost always it's
an excitatory and inhibitory there's a
very small number of split spines and a
very fair very very small number we only
found one trifer cated is fine axons
however have lots of varicosities and we
found that 25 to 30 percent of the
varicosities are presynaptic to multiple
spines much more so than I would have
expected so most Bouton's are actually
talking to more than one day so cahal
was able to get them with teeth out one
you're on despite being it's one year
onto next i presume they want to get
kind of motifs out but at a network
level is there a kind of network
principles that you expect to find or
you want to or dream about finding yeah
I think this is truly descriptive and
you know I am an unabashed descriptive
biologist and I know this is you know
people reject my papers because they're
descriptive so I you know I know saying
I'm descriptive is not a good thing but
for me what what's held us back a little
bit are these big ideas they're very
very compelling but they're not actually
based in data and genomics is kind of
the same way you know once you have a
genome you don't have to have a great
idea you you actually now have the goods
to see what actually is the case so what
what we're spending most of our time on
is figuring out how to mind this
database so the the paper that is not
yet submitted but will be quite soon
provides the reader with this database
where you can go in and basically pull
out any subset of the objects and render
them see how they're connected and the
entire connectional matrix is also
online and every statistical test we've
done is online including the software we
used and we wrote so everything we're
trying to make this kind of accessible
data
my noble data but making images my novel
data has turned out for us to be much
more difficult much harder than actually
generating the data which wasn't easy
but turning this into something that's
actually scientifically useful like a
like genomics is a you know we're really
in the early days of that but that's my
hope I'd I don't have a strong
hypothesis so how much into subject
variation surely you're joking
we've done three billions of the brain
we've done three cylinders and they all
and they're contiguous and they all show
the same properties but it's very
unlikely this is just one little part of
the dendritic spines of one neuron and a
neighboring neuron it's very unlikely
that at this level of resolution until
we do much much larger things would we
even be able to have a regular data set
to compare but nonetheless we are now
doing exactly this analysis in an animal
that has a behavioral mutation in
development an animal with profound
behavioral problems just to see at this
level are there any quantitative
differences between normal and abnormal
and obviously for that we have a control
as well an age matched genetically same
background animal between the rainbow
and connectomics do you see any more
high throughput method in between that
can sort of get you some a rough draft
of the diagram war yeah so the automatic
segmentation algorithms can now
recognize synapses and can trace wires
I hope within a year or two they will
generate wiring diagrams with no human
intervention I think is the more we can
get humans out of this the smaller my
lab gets and a lot of the people working
my labs say you know they're saying
building their own obsolescence in here
but the ultimate aim is is to get the
human out of this just like in genomics
and get as much of this data done
without humans doing any of it yeah
yeah so I didn't talk about this at all
it's really fascinating you know you can
count the number of synaptic vesicles
you can measure the size of the
postsynaptic density and you can look at
the size of the spine and we did that
for every synapse every one of the 1,500
synapses and we had a great control here
we have two synapses of the same axon on
the same target cell where the
presynaptic activity is identical
because they're the same axon just
branched the postsynaptic activity is
identical because they're both spines on
the same apical dendrite the molecular
things are the same we can ask well are
how similar are those two spines they're
as biologically similar as any spines
possible and we compared them to two
spines innovated by different axons on
the same dendrite and two spines
innervated by the same axon on different
dendrites we have three groups here and
indeed axons that innervate the same
dendrite at two sites their spines are
more similar but not nearly as similar
it's just statistically slightly more
similar than two spines innervated by
the same axon on different dendrites the
range in vesicle number is profound we
have some synapses on spines that have
twenty or thirty vesicles and other that
have five or 600 the axons that make
multi synaptic varicosities with huge
numbers of vesicles do that over and
over again so there's classes of axons
that make bigger synapses but it's much
more variable than I had hoped
I hope that we would have clones you
know that a particular spine shape if
it's related to activity to synapses by
the same axon on the same target cell
should look identical and they often
don't so what can I say